what up y'all you know what it is your
math freeway ricky ross and i'm on my
man bootleg care podcast check him out
boulet cab show we got a special guest
in here this guy's a legend freeway
ricky ross is in the building what's up
kev man it's it's good to uh finally
meet you shout out to my guy amir who
connected us i feel like i i i've been
trying to interview you for so long i
just i just wanna roll up i walk the
streets every day man all you have to do
is just holler out it's good to finally
meet you man i obviously uh i've been
following your story for a really long
time um
you've done such a good job of um
building an enterprise building building
uh
just
different streams of revenues that you
got out of since you got out man i mean
i feel like you just you got out and the
real work started right yeah ain't no
question well not really because i i
worked when i was in jail
believe it or not i did not have enough
time when i was in jail i wanted more
time
really yeah i wished i had more time so
how would you spend your days like in
and in what ways were you still working
on outside stuff while you were
incarcerated every day every day um you
know i was
getting schooled by windy day on
marketing winning days uh legend in the
music industry yep i was one of my
personal coaches you know we emailed
back and forth four or five times a day
um
i just i just tried to stay touched and
in touch with with the streets you know
what was going on who was moving
um
you know you'd be surprised if some of
the people that that i was communicating
with from behind the bars
who was somebody i mean obviously you
mentioned windy day but were there any
anybody else that um whether it was
actors directors artists musicians that
would snoop dre
they all reached out well they
necessarily didn't reach outreach out to
them yeah you know um i knew somebody
with with connections bernard hopkins
um
shout out to bernard hopkins bernard
hoffman's a real one who well
it's a lot of people you know i found
alcoholics while i was in jail
you found the licks yeah i found the
licks you talking about tash
king tea well king tea was a part of the
liquid yeah king tea was was you know uh
king t wasn't in i listened
i'll be the king of hip-hop wow i did
not listen to keem what what did king t
tell you
well i i i was
i was hanging out with dick griffey by
the way shout out to jro and e swift i
just want to make sure i know all three
i know all three members of the licks
i i was hanging out with a guy by the
name of older smith who uh was the owner
of beverly glen music
uh he introduced me to dick griffey
barry gordy
and
at the same time i'd already started
dipping into hip hop
this is why you're no no this is before
this is before okay so this is why i
went to prison before nwa
okay uh at that time
my dmc might have been so this is like
early to mid 80s yeah yeah yeah
so i was already dipping in hip hop you
know we had the dj equipment and you
know we're doing we're doing a little
thing
uh
king t told me
to mess with him dj pooh
but instead i gave him money to older
smith to do anita baker's first record
wow
and had i known that hip-hop
was going to be what it became i would
have went on and did
dj pooh album anyway
instead of not doing it you know i still
could have did it but i was like this
young boy he was only about 17 years old
yeah king t for people people don't give
him enough credit he's one of the
young pioneers in in l.a dre dre learned
how to work the drum machine from master
spade and king t mm-hmm
now king t doesn't get enough flowers oh
no no well you know and that's why when
when when
uh when king t was going through his
little thing you know drake gave him a
deal right uh uh i don't remember what
year it was but dre gave him a nice
little deal you know trying to try to
try to uh boost him up get him back on
his feet but yeah king t had told me
to mess with hip hop he was like stick
with the hip-hop stick with the hip-hop
and and
you know i'm listening to these guys
they got platinum albums and and
you know walls decorated look like your
wall right here so i'm like who do you
listen to the 17 year old kid
or the pioneers of of r b
and uh it was it was a decision that was
easy for me to make you know i went with
them of course um how did you discover
the licks
from from
well
when when i was in mdc mm-hmm as soon as
i walked in the door the first person i
ran into was harry oh
so harrio pulled me into his cell we
were sally's and uh you and harry over
sellies yeah we were sally's okay when
when they started death row okay okay
that's that's that's crazy to know
because i mean just the chances of that
happening
like you guys ended up i mean but you
know you're talking about
guys who who pretty much ran the streets
out here
and
um even though we wasn't really good
friends on the street
you know we we were kind of compatible
you know you want to be you don't want
to be in the cell with somebody that you
can't
talk to relate to you relate to you know
you want to be with somebody that you
can relate to if you're going to have a
salary first you don't want to sally but
if you're going to have one you want
somebody to be somebody who you could
actually be friends with yes so
when i leave mdc and go to the pen
in arizona i get to the pen they turn on
bt and there there was snooping dr dre
187 on undercover cop what prison were
you at in uh arizona phoenix arizona or
what which was a buckeye
no black canyon okay okay the name of
that is fci phoenix is what it's called
okay but it's in black canyon okay uh
so when i saw that i was like damn
harry found to make it
you know death row is finna blow so i
got right on the phone man where king t
yet give me king t number so they gave
me king t number i was like man i need
the artist
and uh he was like
my video finna drop saturday look at my
video let me know if you like these
little dudes it was the licks the
alcoholics man shout out to tash and
those guys and then what's even colder
than that they living with my cousin
really
they really related to you you didn't
even know it yeah they was living with
my cousin so it was it was a real easy
fix and then uh
fate i don't know if you know faye
debian i know of faith well faye was
also uh fate was at that time faye was
the head promoter over the loud records
but he was gonna quit loud records and
come and run freeway records for me wow
so doing that transition he got the job
over the interscope
and
he was still gonna quit though and come
in and and and run my label that was
that was our plan he was going to quit
his job and come around my label i go to
the hole
that's when one of my partners was in
the hole he told me to call this girl
and and
uh the case manager called me and and
locked me up so
um
when i go to the hole i'm in the hole
like 30 days no phone call no mail no
nothing
faith signing the loud records
wow yeah because they ended up on loud
with like that's how they hang it that's
how they that's how they ended up around
with uh
with uh riskings and they probably could
have should have ended up on freeway
records
yeah they should have and and then you
know i was you know i was kind of due to
where i wasn't gonna like
sweat you know like
it wasn't their fault that i went to the
hole and and even though we had already
agreed on on the deal and everything i
just like
go ahead y'all do your thing
so take me back you said that you
bankrolled anita uh baker's first record
mm-hmm so how did because you know
obviously in your position you have a
lot of money that you need to put places
and you need to yeah i was looking for i
was looking for legitimate businesses
things to get me out of the dope game of
course i didn't want to be in the dope
game
so how
how does this anita baker story happen
because i mean obviously you told us you
linked with uh i'm you just said his
name i'm sorry older smith photo smith
when i was in high school
and and another mistake i made not being
young you know not really understanding
business at the time i was a tennis
player
okay oda smith had a son
that he wanted to be a professional
tennis player
his son was about three years younger
than me so otis would come pick me up
from high school
would pay me twenty dollars for me and
at that time that was a lot of money
yeah 20 bucks back then i mean 20 bucks
in the 90s was lit buy me tennis shoes
would buy me rackets to go and play with
his son i play with his son just about
every day wow after school i would
finish at the tennis team do my little
tennis practice at the school and then
he would pick me up we'd go to beverly
hills hollywood uh it was another place
where kennedy got killed at it used to
be a tennis club really nice telescope
he he he was a few tennis clubs he was
the only black
that went there nobody else l.a tennis
club in hollywood he was the only member
for the longest there was no other black
member beside older smith in that club
so he would take me to those places and
and and i would play with his son you
know hour hour and 20 minutes whatever
whatever time it took us to play a
couple sets
so
i grew up though yeah after i was 16 17
i think 1718 i stopped playing with him
i dropped out of high school
and and went back to the streets so we
hadn't saw each other for years and all
this is in my book if you you get a
chance yeah your book's been out for a
while too it's been about five years
yeah it's been out for me but they still
don't know why you know about it yeah
it's still kind of like unknown you know
we're still buying it on amazon i'm sure
don't go to amazon and get it don't go
no where should they go go to freeway
ricky ross and get my book buy the book
there that way you can get it
autographed you get it autographed and
you get to keep all the money
you don't got to give amazon their cut
yeah i don't want to get jeff pizzo
nothing he's got enough i'm hating on
jeff yeah for sure
rich [ __ ] go to space so uh uh
i loved otis let me say that there yeah
so one day i'm just like chilling out
right here in santa monica it was a
professional tennis tournament going on
and i ain't seen notice in five six
years you know i got hair on my face now
i'm a grown man getting money i ain't 16
no more and i got about two three
million dollars cash
and uh i'm at the tennis court i'm by
myself you know no no homies don't want
to go no tennis match and i just kicked
back on the bench and got my hand got my
cell phone and you know just relaxing
this is a relaxed day
and then i look up there was little
oldest
nice like six feet three and hit his son
his son yeah hitting the ball a ton
and he's playing against the number one
guy from stanford
big guy looks like a linebacker
and they start arguing
and then the guy from stanford the whole
team is backing him mm-hmm
otis he's playing at ucla the only black
guy on the team right nobody backing him
himself
i said man
i better get some help so i got on the
phone i called all the guys i was like
man some some white boys trying to jump
on me out here in santa monica come at
boo
you know they was in l.a we in santa
monica it was then like five minutes i
heard motorcycles tires screeching and
it's a hell of a that's a hell of a time
to get that far as soon as they come
the kid who who little oldest is arguing
with hit the daddy in the eye bam
and then my guys just coming over the
fence i see them coming over the fence
and they looking at me like
you do that
and and they don't even know all this
but they just know it's a black guy and
a white guy fighting so and then i just
gave him the nod and and they wouldn't
handle a business so
um when they broke it all i wouldn't
broke it all up i didn't want none of my
guys going to jail so that relationship
kept it started all over again it
started all over in that day
so otis don't even know that i did that
for him right like he don't know who
what happened he just know man damn
somebody saved my life because he was
trying to get mastercard i can imagine
so uh then the tennis coach my high
school tennis coach comes up he's the
one that introduced me to oldest
because he knew i needed money in high
school so
uh they started talking and i'm just
standing back to the side listening you
know glad to see my old coach again you
know uh because my coach was nice to me
you know he he he helped me out a lot in
life
um so i would start telling him about
the music business cause i never knew i
just knew all this drove a brand new
rolls royce convertible you know in the
70s like right i don't know what you do
you know i don't even care what you do
right just keep giving me them 20s
so he was talking to coach smith about
the music business and he's like man
rick is the one that uh you should be
talking to he got more money than sin
and and uh
he always looked at me and he was trying
to figure out did he know me
he's like little rick man
he's like little rick
he was like yeah so then i came over we
shook hands and he's like man it's been
a long time i'm gonna take you out for
dinner
and uh then the coach said he probably
won't save your life out here
so the relationship started the next day
he took me up to his office you know
showed me all the plaques you know
johnny taylor right he found rick james
you know uh his listen he just he was
just decorated
so i was already dipping in hip-hop
right then
you know i was messing with some local
rappers here and i had i had some
rappers from chicago i'd already sent
four that eventually signed with russell
simmons
what was their names
six pack or something like that there
they didn't get big right okay
you know they got a little mediocre yeah
local you know local celebrities
so
um
oda started talking to me about this
girl
that he was going to produce
and he needed the money to produce her
he didn't have the money to send for i i
gave him the money to send her her
ticket from detroit to come out here
and uh we got our apartment up in
hollywood hills you know just started
from there i need a baker i need a baker
i never got into the business though
you know i just gave him the money here
here's the money here's the money
so uh did you get a return on your
investment no
she jumped the label she oh okay okay
she jumped the label went to uh
i forgot the name of the label i paid
for the attorney to sewer oh wow
it's crazy because like
i think so many people have kind of like
based on
i guess the misconception that like
snowfall is like directly about you even
though they didn't
they couldn't say that because they
didn't drop the bag off that they should
have probably dropped the bag off for
you but they might be getting ready to
drop it now you know i got the phone
call they want to they want to sit down
they want to sit down
in terms of what though i don't know
in terms of like bringing you into the
fold you just told me they want me to
come to the studio
what are we going to talk about i don't
even know the snowfall producers or the
network or
the show i mean obviously john singleton
passed away rest in peace they said he
said was a producer
i mean but it has to do with snowfall or
is it separate no there's snowfall
i mean i mean because i mean listen when
anyone who's familiar with your story
i mean like well they know they changed
commercials when when they add the first
commercials on snowfall my fans gave
them the blues
hashtag john singleton snowfall i mean
fx all of them hey this is rick's story
y'all stole rick's story yeah i mean
obviously it's not the same
because then then you could sue the
living [ __ ] out of them
have did you try to sue
no i thought about it i talked to a few
lawyers it it's it's a tough suit it is
a tough it can be one it's a tough
lawsuit it's a tough lawsuit um intimate
domain you know i got so much stuff in
newspapers horizon and right right right
right so so if you think about like the
show uh
uh i mean
as far as the first season i guess
like i guess
how much of that do you feel like was
really i didn't watch it you didn't
watch it okay i i only started watching
the show after i got the call from dave
and he wanted me to come be a part of
his podcast
after the snow before that i never
watched snowfall i i probably had
glanced you know passing by and and and
and and seeing it on tv now i did have
dinner uh lunch with franklin before i
was at whole foods downtown with the
actor yeah the english guy uh something
idris is his name i forget his first
name yeah i don't know his name but uh
seems like i'm terrible with names seems
like a nice guy
very nice guy i like him so you guys had
dinner
lunch lunch you guys had lunch did he
like try to pick your brain or or how
was that combo
i was sitting there because i didn't
know who he was okay because you're like
i don't even watch the [ __ ] show i
don't watch the show how would i know
who you are you know and he walked up
and he was like you mr ross and i was
like yeah
and uh
my managers were sitting there and they
was like
that's the guy from snowfall and i was
like what
and i was like sit down you sit down so
he sit down and we just started talking
he was like man i don't know why johnny
got you on the set and
i would do a much better job if i had
you around and you know we just went
through the little thing you know he
probably was blowing a little smoke too
you know of course
of course he runs into u.s
so but it was a cool conversation uh um
and and you know we just got after we
finish eating we just got up and we we
went our separate ways
so
because obviously in the show like
it's very much kind of like i mean
i'm assuming there wasn't a bunch of
tennis players in your hood where you
were growing up at right
i mean for for black tennis players we
probably had the biggest black
population of tennis players maybe in
the country
you go from
were you a good student in school
terrible terrible student
good athlete though
when when i say terrible i mean terrible
as far as is is doing the work and stuff
like that
i didn't really like
mess up a lot in school i was a probably
a good kid but i was a good kid
you weren't applying yourself to school
couldn't read or write you couldn't read
and write no oh wow okay so
um
take me like to like the
is the
parallels of
the show and cia and obviously we all
know that the contra wars were being
funded through all this crazy ass [ __ ]
that was going on with the cia was that
is that part accurate in terms of what
you were dealing with with your plug and
all that [ __ ] i didn't know i didn't
know that my guy was a cia operative you
didn't know until you were incarcerated
right when when uh gary webb broke the
story
is when i found out that the guy i've
been getting my drugs from was the cia
operative and how long was that your guy
like like was it from the jump like this
i sold drugs for about eight years he
wasn't the main guy all along but uh you
know you know in the drug business
there's probably three or four guys in
between
there is so you have to work your way
through each
level of of of participants in order to
get to the top hunt show were there
situations in which you felt like
the fact that you were indeed dealing
with law enforcement without knowing it
and that they kind of needed you out on
the streets
getting this money no i had to totally
totally opposite
because you know they had the freeway
task force
the so they had the free but but the the
freeway was separate they were separate
separate from them so the freeway task
force is is is kicking my ass that's the
lapd
versus the shifts laps lapd and sheriffs
which have no idea about this other
thing that's going on over here at the
cia they found out after they rate it as
well that do you think that they like
the cia like maybe protected you in
certain aspects where that could have
been worse on the sheriff and lapd like
was there like an invisible hand that
maybe
kind of thinks so handcuffed and and hog
tied your legs hogtied and beating the
head with a flashlight and a dog body
[ __ ] crazy
uh do you think you were protected would
you feel like you was protected probably
not no probably not so i didn't feel
like i was protected what was the first
like um time where you decided like
this is something i need to really do
was it because you know like you said
like when it comes to dealing drugs i've
sold weed and other things
um
there's like a moment where you realize
oh there's real money here
like you start off a certain way like at
what point in time did you realize
i could turn this into an enterprise was
it like after you've got your first key
like what no no
my first my first 50 i got beat out of
i sold it to one of the big homies well
i didn't sell it to him we didn't know
what it was me and my boy who who i was
working we didn't know we didn't know
what cocaine was i've never seen cocaine
before and this is prior to
the crack era really kicking in yeah
this is still powder this is straight
power i mean they rocking it up but we
didn't know how you didn't know what the
[ __ ] it was freebasing wasn't popular
yet i guess right free basin was yeah
freebasing was was
it was popular but not to me
um
and it had richard pryor had already
been freebasing okay you know richard
pride already been getting down
so
i had never saw cocaine i never saw
wheat at the time i mean i was a tennis
player that's what i mean yeah
i was a square
so when
my partner called me over and showed me
the cocaine for the first time
i don't know because i saw cocaine was
on superfly
some real [ __ ] yeah
so
i was a novice
so you
i got beat out my first 50. when you say
that what do you mean
okay he took it my guy martin who was
the big homie took it
rocked it up
and he sampled it
and at that time he got back up a piece
of rock that was about the size of a
match here you've probably never seen a
match
uh of course i've seen a match come on
you've seen the matches before 35 from
35 i'm like 12. you can go to 7-eleven
and get free matches right now yeah they
still have matches yeah they got to i
don't know if you buy cigarettes you can
say i need a matchbook i am saw a match
in 34 years [ __ ] they're still out there
okay well anyway it's about the size of
a match here and he said well
it rocked up but now i gotta taste it
and he cut a little piece off of it and
it was just a teeny piece left and he
threw it on the pipe and he tasted it
and he said
i need another taste
and next thing you know it's like a
little little teeny weeny piece he said
man i'm gonna just smoke then i'll pay
you friday
that's 50 bucks worth right
so now with my boy 50 bucks i'm already
broke
so i'm really [ __ ] up now
so i'm sitting on the porch again
like damn i gotta call the homie and
tell him i ain't got his 50. right 50
bucks that made a decent amount of money
no back then it was it was a nice piece
of money yeah so uh
i guess about an hour or two later
uh martin pulled up again the one who
had smoked all the rock and he had big
mouths with him this is the first time i
ever met big mouse mouse
used to hang out with tookie williams
and he's one of one of their guys you
know swole and yeah he jumped out he had
a hundred dollars he's like man we want
a hundred dollars worth for that
and i was like damn i ain't got it
so i said let me go call my boy so i
called mike i told mike everything that
happened you're like look man i ain't
got your 50. but i got somebody here 100
well you got 100 if you want it you can
come get it i'm gonna get you your 50
whenever i get it yeah and he's like i'm
on my way
it was my first sale and i was like damn
this [ __ ] got value it got value
that's crazy at what point in time
did you realize that um re-rocking
cocaine was the most profitable
business
model for you to to really get to get
the most out of out of what you were
getting from well well how that kind of
came about is is people would come over
early in the mornings you know seven
eight in the morning before they go to
work you know they want to get a hit
before they go to work and they'd be
like
damn man i ain't got no utensils
utensils for the stuff that they cooked
it up with
and i was like oh i got a bottle and i
would let them use my bottle and they'd
cook it up and
and then i was like damn
won't i just have a ready rock form
ready to go
because it's like then we start calling
it ready rock oh we got that ready rock
we got powder we got ready by which one
you want which one do you want and so
more people start asking for rock and
powder and then pretty pretty soon it
just fades powder all the way out
hey we got to stop the interview real
quick man shout out to our sponsors at
my bookie now if you're into sports like
me you like to win money what are we
doing go to my bookie right now man
let's get in on some of this action
my bookie go sign up get the double
deposit bonus that's what this means
when you sign up in my bookie right now
all right whatever money you would
deposit they're gonna match it they're
gonna double it for you up to a thousand
dollars but you gotta use the key word
the promo code
bootleg that's right use that promo code
bootleg when you sign up at mybookie
they're gonna double your deposit listen
march madness is coming up my favorite
time of the year to gamble is march
madness it is so much fun you don't got
to know a [ __ ] thing about college
basketball it is just [ __ ] turnt up i
love to go to
listen march madness that's really all
you need to know get your account before
then thank me later also nba action is
finally back throw down some futures who
do you think is going to win the mvp
joel embiid jokic devin booker a little
dark horse you know i'm saying shout out
to the suns uh you got to go to my
bookie though sign up get down right now
all right get double your money double
your deposit you put in a thousand
they're gonna match that give you a
whole nother thousand to gamble with
mybookie.ag
use the promo code bootleg double your
deposit my my own close family members
had their bouts
early on in my childhood with crack but
crack is like one of those things that
like i i feel like when you when you see
the things people go through to get it
and they know that it's detrimental to
their lifestyle but they still go
through all those things and they still
it's almost like
being a crackhead is like a real
full-time job just to get high
it's like it's like it's like if you
wake up every day and your goal is to
get crap it's like that's like your full
time
they'll become your goal yeah i saw
people quit
you know before i started selling crack
with quit jobs that we would have killed
for right and it's like and like i'm
quitting man i'm gonna come out there
and work with y'all like homie you ain't
gonna make it out here in these streets
did you ever try it i tried it for about
two weeks
and
what i i mean i got sick you got sick
thank god because if you really liked it
you would have i would i mean i i i
annoying me i would have had the
strength to quit though yeah and i've
had friends that i've helped quit
you know like was was out there and and
they came back and then started having
money
yeah it's crazy because you think of
like
some of the
you know
i guess
when you think of
being a drug dealer the moral
i guess the moral uh
line that you're walking
where it's like okay at the time you
don't understand
in 20 or 25 years from now how
you're going to be
necessarily affecting
all the yeah the crack era absolutely
like you don't know that when you're
living it because it's it's it's you
know you can't see it there's nobody
nobody really knew though yeah no one
knew right nobody knew about crack at
that time yeah it was something new and
i'm sure it started off as people doing
it recreationally because i have friends
like brian sampson shout out my guy
brian who did crack in the 80s he used
to say used to just freebase before he
[ __ ] he'd be like oh yeah we used to do
it in the 80s but like we didn't really
know it was crack yet we just called it
free basin right you know you're you're
absolutely right so like people p i
think it started off as something where
and the people who was doing it all have
money because you figured you figured
back then when when when i started a
grammar cocaine was worth like
350 375 for a gram so
everybody couldn't afford to freebase
extremely rich
and and at the time there was no ready
rock
so people had to buy that and then do
that [ __ ] on their own like you said
right
do you think that you were keep the base
in they used to eat the base when i
first started they was eat the basement
were you um
were you think you were the one of the
first people who who decided to
pre-package and have it ready the ready
rock aspect you know l.a times said i
was the first crack millionaire you know
um
and you know it's hard to say
we don't keep stats you know we just we
just be trying to stack as much money as
we can
do you feel any sort of remorse or guilt
just kind of knowing like your part in
in the crack epidemic
well you know what people ask me that
and and i used to contemplate with how
to answer that question but i know how
to answer it now
i did an article with a young lady in uh
chicago from the chicago tribune
and
when she headlined her article
she said
no regrets only lessons
so i learned a lot from uh being in the
cocaine game uh you know i'm happy with
myself right now you know i'm happy with
my life i'm happy to have my life turn
out you know even my prison time you
know i accept that as being part of
my journey of my uh rights to passage
and and i'm who i am right now had i
never uh
been involved with cocaine i couldn't be
who i am today you know i wouldn't be
able to do the things that i'm gonna do
in the future
uh were there ever little things that
happened where you were dealing with
your plug that might have like that in
retrospect
you think back on or you thought back on
when you realized that they were indeed
you know cia or whatever
were there ever like little things
you're like you know what now that now
that i know that this
it kind of makes like
nothing like what they're doing on snow
on snowfall uh
you know i'm looking at these guys they
like walk through locks doors and walls
and you know they got super senses you
know they can just like figure out and
somebody's watching them and right no
that [ __ ] don't really happen in the
dope game you know we just like normal
[ __ ] we make mistakes you know
if you forget [ __ ]
uh
but no
um
do you remember
that like the time you you you knew for
the first time you had a million dollars
because i feel like that first millions
got to be memorable
i mean there was times where you were
making three million dollars a day right
the hundred thousand my first hundred
thousand was more memorable than your
first million yeah than my first million
because you know
the dope game is it's kind of funny
because once you make a hundred thousand
it gets really easy to make a hundred
thousand
that's
a lot of people don't know that but to
get to an ounce
was tough
that was like
like pulling teeth out to get to an
ounce of cocaine you know to save up
twenty eight hundred dollars they're
like wow i ain't gonna never get there
and then
once i did it it was like
four ounces and ten ounces a hundred
ounces you know just like kept spinning
and that's the same way with money you
know once you get to a certain level say
for instance when you're working with a
hundred thousand it's easy to
profit thirty forty thousand dollars
yeah i mean once you have that hundred k
you start playing in a different game in
terms of the amount of money you can
can generate can generate a hundred
percent because you you really really
what what what you do is is what i did
so you see like what i found out about
myself is that
um
i don't look at myself no more as a
cocaine dealer i was a cocaine banker
so i would do like banks do go get money
from somebody
and then take it and break it down to a
bunch of other people and then make a
percentage off of each one of those
people and that's how my money was
generated wow so yeah that makes sense
cocaine banker i like that
i like that that's that's that's pretty
wild
um for people who don't know what area
of la uh what was your neighborhood
south central
57 okay so
when you're growing up um
you're coming up in the late 70s early
80s right 60s
um i was there when the watch riots
happen that's crazy yeah i saw that
yeah i was there i saw the burn baby
burn you know the
army tanks rolling down the street the
army man i mean you're there for the
beginning of what we you know is you
know we live in l.a so we're fully at
least you know obviously both of us but
a lot of people um culturally think of
la they think of the two biggest gangs
in the world are the bloods and crips in
terms of just culturally right and like
i feel like
you're come up you were actually kind of
there before
bloods and crips were world famous you
were probably
running a lot of those blocks before it
became like a thing
well no they was there before i started
selling coke they were there already i'm
just i'm just curious like
that
uh that i remember when the crips and
bloods played football against each
other
wow
before they were enemies you know i
remember the first person that got
killed at the park
you know we we had uh all all my little
crew we all rode our bikes to the beach
and
uh we we sneaked you know sneaking right
our bikes to the beach who was only
about 10 years old
but uh back then you know you could you
could run around there lane didn't have
to be you know worried about nothing
happened to you i wouldn't let my 10
year old kids run the streets now in l.a
but of course back then we did it you
know about 10 of us 15 of us we get on
our bikes and we just ride to the beach
and we were coming back from the beach
this night and it was just before uh
dawn you know was still the sun was
still up a little bit and when we got to
the park we see the park taped off and
cops everywhere
and
was like what happened and then uh we
found out that one of the crips killed
blood
that's a while over a football game over
a football game
one of them's tooth got knocked out
and from there it was just it was
starting to fly escalating and then the
other one went to the car and got his
gun
that's so crazy what um
because it would have been easy for you
to get sucked into that life right i
wanted to be a [ __ ] you wanted to be a
[ __ ] yeah
what was it that was about 12. i was
going to say what was it because because
you know you're obviously running your
enterprise later on
was it
easy to navigate kind of being
independent if that makes sense well you
know i was i was a kid i was only 12
years old so i just mean in terms of
when you started to finally kind of get
into the streets well when i came back
to the streets though when i quit
playing tennis i was a grown man but i
mean i mean did you still have to kind
of deal with some of those politics yeah
but there was my homeboys okay i went to
school with them
it's like my neighborhood is like
the crips is right here
on figaro
and then you go a block or two over it's
the bloods right
so it's only like it ain't even a
quarter mile between you know the two
sets you know like the two sets kind of
like mingle in each other on certain
areas you know like you'd be walking
down the street and you see the bloods
walking on that street and then
you know you see the crips just just a
little off so
they were they were close
to each other you know that's crazy
because like i just feel like that was
because now we think of like i i mean
there's blood sets and crib sets all
over the world and just like
i guess though it's amazing i never
would have thought that at one time yeah
it's wild it is crazy and and even when
we think of just gangs in general we
just think of crypts i mean in in the
united states like people think of
crypts and bloods as like the two
biggest gangs like obviously there's
motorcycle gangs there's hell's angels
is all that but hopefully sure it's a
wild it's a wild thing to think that you
were there well the christian bloods get
the most notoriety probably you know out
of
it's something about you know being
black in america
where um
they like to promote negative stuff
about us that's true
and then also just the um you know it
even it even baffles me when when i went
to jail you know i made every news
channel
in the country
nightline dateline 20 20 60 minutes
well i've been out i spoke at stanford
university yale nigel um that's not on
dateline that's not on 2020. yeah
they're not they haven't said nothing
about it of course not
yeah i mean it's the same way that like
and and for me unlike you got a guy that
was illiterate
now he's getting paid to talk at
stanford university usc law school ucla
i mean if that ain't some amazing [ __ ]
what is what is
for a guy who couldn't read right now
the universities are paying him to go
and talk to the smartest students i'm
like what the [ __ ] it's just it's just
this society man
it's like when you when we think of like
when you turn on the news like they're
not talking about the good [ __ ] going on
they're only talking about the [ __ ] and
that's the stuff that really like
like like even i even broke down the
john singleton situation right mm-hmm
because i knew john [ __ ] with me right
he [ __ ] with me for real you know i
know when [ __ ] faking of course
so me and him sit down we chopping there
we're going to aid together so i know
that he he liked me yeah
so i was thinking a couple weeks ago
like when i started doing this show
after the snow with with uh dave you
know i started really like just
opening my mind up and like really
thinking so i was like damn i bet john
singleton went to fx and say man i got
rick ross and i got this show and they
probably were like we'll take the show
we don't want rick ross
that's interesting i wouldn't doubt it i
mean from all accounts i've heard like
john was a pretty stand-up dude
i don't know well i don't think he
should have did the deal though he
should have said you ain't taking rick
ross you can't have the show
i don't i mean yeah i mean i don't
disagree i mean i don't disagree i mean
i i also think it's obvious that it was
loosely based around your life like uh
it's odd you could go to this page
if you go to john singleton's instagram
page you got me and him hugging taking a
picture with my book
he bought one of my first books and he
said rick ross great story snowfall
coming soon i didn't know it until
somebody brought it to my attention um
that's [ __ ] crazy yeah no that's
that's unfortunate
um
when someone has the amount of money
that you have you start to learn you're
kind of forced to learn some financial
literacy right
because that's a lot of [ __ ] money
um your money to teach you what are some
of the lessons that having that much
wealth accumulated at such a young age
that you learned that you would try to
spread to other people because because
financial literacy is one of those
things that
you know unfortunately isn't taught in
schools enough well i learned that your
money will work harder than you
you know a lot of people try to work to
make money but you should let money work
for you
that's some real [ __ ]
and and basically i figured that out and
once i did that's when i would go buy a
million dollars worth of cocaine and
then i would pass it out to different
people
and then the next day they would all
bring me my money back because you ain't
standing on the corner selling your
[ __ ] self exactly
what were that's your money working for
you yeah i mean and i think that in in
terms of just what the wealthiest people
we know that's what they do oh
absolutely whether they have stocks that
go up and down whether they i mean [ __ ]
as simple as a vending machine you have
a vending machine that vending machine
you're not there the vending machine is
making your money working it's working
for you
yeah if you go out and buy bulldozer
that's your money working piece of
property rent it out there it is
was there any assets you were able to
keep after you got arrested or did they
take everything i had a few i had a few
pieces of property uh you know i saw on
the theater on crenshawn adams
um
i was gonna be on the west coast apollo
over there
and uh
what else i had i had a few pieces of
property
you know uh i sold my motel before they
before they indict i mean once i knew
that i was indicted i started trying to
sell my assets because i knew that it
was coming yeah they was going to try to
take the big ones my lawyer was like get
rid of everything that you think they
know about you knew it was coming
oh you had an idea well what happened is
is even though my indictment was a
secret indictment
um
one of my cousins killed himself
and i go to the scene because i couldn't
believe he did it so i go over there
where he was at and then one of the cops
had had pete me
and then uh somebody was like man that
cop just mentioned your name to the
other cop and i was like i ain't
tripping i'm good you know i hadn't even
been selling dope for a year and a half
at that time
and uh
the cop came over and he was like
uh you rick ross and i was like nah
and i had fake id so let me see your id
so i pulled out my bunk id and i hand it
to him
and um
he was looking at his partner's point
right that's him
and when he said that dude said turn
around
when cuffed me i took off running
so i knew from that day that uh
i was wondering something was coming
because they would go they're trying to
throw you in some cars
so you started to get your assets in
order
or get your assets
liquidated i called a lawyer the next
day like man they was going to arrest me
out here
you must have a fire ass lawyer in the
80s i did i did they didn't like him
either though
is he still is he still practicing law
i don't know he don't got oh yeah he's
about 70 something years old now i
always think you ever watch breaking bad
i never watched it he's got this the guy
he's a big meth dealer and he's got this
like go-to lawyer saul goodman he's like
crazy guy but i can imagine being
your lawyer in the 80s had to be a
stressful and also profitable gig to
take yeah he made a lot of money yeah i
bet he did
i bet he didn't kept us out of jail
though i bet he did that was that was
the most important thing is keep my guys
out of jail that had to be nice to have
somebody like that in your corner to
kind of guide you through the legalities
of like hey oh yeah if you're gonna if
you're gonna take your money and put it
here do it this way really one of the
best things he ever told me was uh i go
to him and i was like man these cops
playing dope
planting dope yeah they was playing dope
on this yeah because they couldn't catch
us they couldn't figure out
how to catch us with dope you know we
we i came up with a theory was that we
don't keep dope in the house
we brain in the house we wear it up as
soon as we wear that we throw it in the
trunk of a car put the car down the
street in front of somebody else's house
so they was never going to catch us with
dope unless they called us like right
during that time right he was waiting
that specific instance and then we
started wearing it up at three in the
morning four in the morning you know
like odd hours of the day when most
people would be asleep so people
wouldn't see us
going in houses or something like that
because you know people would see me
sometime and recognize me and be like oh
that's a red cross
so we just started doing it when most
people would be asleep so nobody
wouldn't really recognize it so
the cops couldn't catch us with dope
and back then it wasn't no
conspiracy you know like uh
well conspiracy somebody got to get
caught with some dope with a conspiracy
or somebody got to come in and say that
you had some dope but anyway
they started planting the drugs on us
they started right in the house
and we literally
take dope out of their pocket and plant
it in the house or take bags of dope out
of the trunk of their car
and so how did your lawyer tell you to
navigate through that well when i told
him about it he didn't believe it you
know california yeah no that's a crazy
thing yeah ain't nobody doing no [ __ ]
like that in california so he said
if if if i knew some cops was was was
crooked like that there i would hire a
private investigator to investigate the
cops
that's what i did
so you would hire a private investigator
now
this would be pre them planning drugs or
after they'd already been planting drugs
they're planting drugs on my people
already they hadn't planted drugs on me
and you knew who these cops were
yeah so you would say the freeway task
force they was named after me so you
would hire a private investigator to
investigate those cops yeah and just get
get [ __ ] on them yeah
that's great what was the craziest thing
that your pi dug up on a cop
uh this one guy was was was um in the
bed with this girl
and he had a fish tank right next to his
bed
where one of the pumps had a shortage in
it
so it was electrocuting
they stuck the guy onto the wire
and and lecture community
so the cops
did that to someone yeah
and your pi
witnessed this he didn't witness it but
the the the defendants
or the witnesses told him
that that's what happened to him another
one was uh my partner
uh we used to have big safe probably
like the size of this table in our
apartments
and
they wanted him to open the safe
and he wouldn't open it so they took a
trash bag and put over his head
[ __ ]
some torture and [ __ ] try to suffocate
they got indicted for that
for putting the trash bag over over his
head
smothering wow
so it was almost like
against their best interest to [ __ ] with
you in that way because you had a
[ __ ] guy who's gonna i guess overturn
all that [ __ ] well eventually we we we
got it all over tournament i uh when
when i turned my investigation in 150
people got out of prison
when you when you ended up going in or
when you ended up turning in and died of
me i got they eventually indicted me
okay so when they indicted me
you had all this [ __ ] that your p.i had
accumulated like oh you're going to go
to trial with these guys this is these
things what we got on them this your
witnesses right let me show you a
terrible witness let me show you who
your witnesses is wow
that's crazy that's how that's how i
beat my first case shout out to your pi
huh is he i mean that's your lawyer and
your pi in the 80s god bless them they
had
top of the line guys
he probably did now too his name was
frenchie frenchie yeah
i mean so he knew yeah he knew he knew
the ropes he knew the ropes but those
are the guys that you get for
investigators you know if you do an
investigation on cops you know you want
somebody who's who's been there done
that
that's some real [ __ ] when you're um
coming up in l.a in the 80s
the early uh
stages of gangsta rap iced tea i think
of ice tea i think
guys like that like uh
how much was
like hip-hop and guys like like ice and
and you know obviously nwa was a little
bit later
um
we were moving tiny tea
master spade
king t master spade yeah i was going to
say like
it's it's kind of like you you
you know hip-hop and
the crack era kind of run
synonymous with each other in a lot of
ways definitely definitely um you know i
see that the the documentary um planet
rock right how hip-hop stole from the
dope game
um
but like i was gonna i got i guess
did you also kind of recognize that this
hip-hop thing was
was becoming like a real thing that um
i did not i i cause some people because
back then a lot of people thought it was
a fad or it was like it wasn't real
music because it was it wasn't going to
last long
that's what all this and dick griffey
and them told me that that it was going
to be like disco
because disco was there and then it
wasn't exactly and that's why i miss
hip-hop if it wouldn't have been for
that he would if they would have told me
that i would i would have been the king
of hip-hop without question nobody
i remember when russell simmons was
running around l.a broke
wow
i remember that and you had the money to
really you could have been the death row
out of l.a
yeah
that's crazy
i mean [ __ ] man
yeah but it ain't too late it ain't too
late no no i'm gonna you know i still
gotta get my money out of the music
industry see what i do is you gotta go
to baker and get your money back no no
i'm gonna get it i'm gonna get it out of
hip-hop hip-hop gonna pay me i like it i
mean [ __ ] has did you end up winning the
rick ross lawsuit no i lost it you did
lose it what was the reason that you
lost it because it seemed like it was a
pretty
well
um with if if if somebody does something
to you you get two years
to see like a statute of limitations
so you were past that i should have
found before i got five days before i
got out of prison i should have found my
lawsuit
but the judge wasn't gonna
just gonna find a way to let them out
did you and
the rapper rick ross ever have any talk
or or or was it kind of smoke on the
phone before you guys didn't
you know when he was you're probably
like you out there running around with
my name huh
it was crazy i when when uh one of the
youngsters you know my my little
youngsters that i had in jail you know
they studied under me one of them ran in
one day with a magazine boom and he
showed me xxl hey man look at this dude
he stole your name
i said huh so i go get on the phone i
start calling everybody hey man you know
this dude x you know this dude yeah
so uh finally uh you gotta i hit one of
my guys in new york he's like man he's
gonna be in my office monday
i was like oh yeah
he's like yeah call at nine o'clock
so when i called he just handed the
phone he didn't even know who it was
yo stop at the interview got to tell you
about our good folks at odd socks man
listen go to oddssoxofficial.com
use the promo code 20 off save 20 off
some of the craziest socks you know they
got the ninja turtle joints uh shout out
to kool-aid you know what i'm saying
shots of spongebob plus
they got the odd socks basics
these are my boys right here i love
these right here you get the plain black
the plain white very comfortable most
comfortable socks in the world to be
honest you know what i'm saying plus
underwear y'all cheese it draws
come on what are we doing go to
oddssoxofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg and save 20
off the most comfortable underwear in
the world [ __ ] all that other [ __ ]
y'all be wearing on your ass throw all
the methicas in the trash all that psd
[ __ ] all that [ __ ] is all
listen man put the mod socks on your ass
cheeks and thank me later
at your peak um liquidity wise what is
the most amount of money you had at one
time
i don't know three and a half million
3.2 million something like that there
you didn't really matter see my i didn't
really care about how much money i had i
want to know how much money i could
spend every day
you were spending a lot
you know if i could make two hundred
three hundred thousand every day i was
good
how much were you spending a month at
your at your peak when you were dope no
i'm just just i'm just on
were you like a flashy guy no
because that's you probably would have
got caught a lot earlier had you yeah no
i bought mostly houses
businesses assets business freak you
know like i'll be riding down the street
and i see a house oh look at that
abandoned house right there
get that just call my girls hey i want
to get this house go get it
when you get incarcerated obviously
before that happens you have i'm sure
you had a close uh
circle of people who helped you with
your affairs who helped you with what
you were doing
um
what happens to them when you go to jail
disappear
when the money runs out everybody runs
out
no more
girls that's crazy it gets lonely
yellow is a lonely place i was going to
say
you had to trust somebody enough to like
handle certain [ __ ] once you like if you
know what's coming once once you get a
life sentence it's theirs
it's no longer yours
don't belong to you anymore
how much would you need it for i was
going to say how much cash do you think
was taken from you by people you know
once you got that sentence because i'm
sure you had cash around who knows man i
mean i i've lost so much money in my
lifetime you know people running off and
beating me out of money is i mean the
numbers this would be crazy it'd be
crazy to think about if we could put it
together what i appreciate about what
you've been doing since you got out is
just like the positive influence you've
been like you were talking earlier
um
you know i feel like your story is an
inspiring one because a lot of people
might
be in that position that you're in and
give up or
i ain't gave up i'm going full steam
ahead well that's what i mean you got
out and just it you just picked right
back up
well no i picked up in jail i taught
myself how to read when i was in jail
i said i mean that's a that's how i got
out i got myself out of prison
why did they why did they let you out
early because i told them that they had
they charged me on a three-strike law
and i told them i wasn't a three-striker
and then i showed them i wasn't a
three-striker
and then you had to get out and they had
to let me out that's a beautiful i'll go
against their books
and one thing about them they don't like
going against their books once they
write it on that paper
it's hard for them to go against those
so um
when i was in prison i went hard man i
didn't uh i read over 300 books while i
was gone
what's the most important book you've
ever read
i would say the three most important
give me the three think and grow rich by
napoleon hill mm-hmm richest man in
babylon by george clooney it's a great
book and as a man think by james allen
those books um
allowed me to go back over my life in a
dope game and break it down
and to
see how i could use those same skills to
do the things that i'm doing right now
richest man in babylon they made us read
it in high school
what
well you went to high school at phoenix
arizona they should be that books i
believe that books should be in every
school in this economics class right but
it was it was a for people who don't
know you should go check it out it's
really extremely basic principles
of financial literacy but not told in
that specific way i guess if that makes
sense yeah like how you should spend
money how you should save money and like
you know oh my guys i i asked all my
guys to read it you know my boxers and
it's not a long book no it's a short
book it's a very short easy read
everyone should go check book
so rappers that i work with boxers that
i work with
anybody want to work with me uh my
assistants i ask them all to read those
books
um
now that you're
you know you got the book's been out for
five years we talked about that you're
working with i got another book i've
been out about a year
what like give us the grand scheme of
everything you have going on now um
you know the books
uh the movie
is budgeted
yeah so let's let's talk about the movie
first cause the your movie's gotta be
this can't just be a [ __ ] straight to
straight to tv type oh no this no this
this theater this has to be uh when we
think about how big snowfall is
and i know that snowfall i mean
officially isn't about you but
the movie's got everybody think it is
the movie's gotta be [ __ ] crazy
absolutely like you michael b jordan or
somebody crazy gotta play you mm-hmm i
don't know
i like i like the uh i like that kid uh
childish gambino childish gambino would
be crazy donald glover playing you would
be crazy he would kill it
i don't disagree
that's what i was going to ask you like
he's the hardest guy in the world to get
i've been looking for that guy for three
years
i mean
he is a very eclectic human
yes
nobody knows his show atlanta is amazing
i don't know if you've seen it it's good
i haven't saw it but uh i i just i just
like his demeanor you know i think that
he could uh that he could pull it off i
just don't want to see your uh your
movie ending up like the gaudy movie
that john travolta starred in recently
because that was straight to amazon and
it was terrible no i don't want to go
straight down your story is so crazy
it's got to be bankrolled it's got to be
it's got to just be a nice budget for a
black movie it's got to be a moment man
it's got to be a moment i'll tell you
that we got reginald hudlin directing
dope
you guys haven't casted it yet no we
haven't cast it yet are you guys going
to make the movie and then shop it
around or do you guys already have
distribution
uh my friends have distribution already
okay yeah they gotta put deal
so uh um we we pretty we're pretty tight
you know i'm i'm i'm i'm pretty dope in
the movie scene too like a lot of people
don't know you know i should scream
movie scripts when i was in jail so they
could let you like you could tell them
this is [ __ ] this isn't how it would
go down that's what i used to do i
actually have stacks of movie scripts
what's the movies that they had you look
through that we might know while you
were locked up which one
ah man i don't remember man i know it
was one about these people who were uh
they were stealing kidneys selling
kidneys oh [ __ ] and they both had boxes
this was this was a crazy movie they
both have boxes uh containers
one had a kidney and one had a bag of
dope and they got mixed up
you know they went to the same
restaurant to meet somebody and the guy
with the kidney gave the guy that was
trying to buy the dope the kidney and
the guy with the kidney he gave the dope
to the guy who needs a kidney so now
you know the guy with the kidney he's
sweating because he about to die
right and the guy with the dope it was
it was it was crazy that was one of the
craziest ones i ever and they they made
the movie about that too it it it made
it too so the movie's coming um
you're obviously speaking at a bunch of
different places which is
i think yep
i'm doing that um the weed [ __ ]
yeah matter of fact i just just come
from out working on my growth spot
yesterday i've been working i'm building
a 40 000 square foot grow spot right now
uh that's gotta be so
ironic and weird to be like i just got i
mean obviously it's cocaine and weed is
two separate things but i mean weed in
in your day for me to have a license you
know yeah and you're like out here like
getting selling drugs legally now yeah
yeah it's a beautiful thing and i want a
dispensary so so i got a dispensary
coming soon
um you know the music i'm working with
dom kennedy now dom's a great guy me and
good friend um
last week i had lunch with uh james
fonda roy that in fact two days in one
week you know nice i'm with james van
der roy for two days in one week so that
was like
damn who get to do that you know what
i'm saying of course uh private
restaurant you know private restaurants
where they tape your phone up you know
you can't take pictures when you're
going to the restaurant so um
you know i just i i just found out how
to get myself in
places that most people can't get in
you know and right now i got to champ
with me you know he he flew out here
from detroit come on man you know i'm
going to introduce you to him you have
to jump over the cord
it's one of my young with my young guys
i'm advising him he's a fighter
and a rapper fighter and a rapper
uh entertainment hey take the mic tell
us plug your [ __ ] man
what up dumb man is abdullah kirar out
of detroit michigan you know flew to l.a
tap in with big we right here with uh
bullet kid going crazy shout out to
detroit i gotta go out to detroit soon
i'm supposed to go out there shoot some
[ __ ] with babyface ray oh yeah come to
the d eastside
going crazy right now oh yeah the whole
culture we we we really like
i want to say the next atlanta because
we really put atlanta on for real i mean
i can't go there with you but
no right now detroit got it we we we
right now shout out uh babyface ray
peasy
42 doug yeah uh payroll giovanni the
whole the whole city going crazy i swear
vezo ice everybody's eating detroit's
going crazy and we all it's like
it's like the streets coming out to the
industry now like autumn all the rappers
you just know they like street rappers
they're not in the industry so like they
kind of
i'm just kidding i'm kidding like we got
yachty coming to the city now for sure
you already did a whole album of t
christmas exactly
detroit theme no no he didn't it was an
album he did a um a a michigan themed
album yeah it's a bunch of detroit
artists yeah yeah michigan boy it was
cool so
you know we all coming up make a lot of
sense because what we have been saying
in jail is that the music business
followed the dope game
where the dope game went the music scene
started to flourish
and and when meech and them went to to
to atlanta you know they have that's
when they helped that thing start to to
jail because you need you know you need
some of some of the trimmings to go with
you know to go do you ever communicate
with someone like big meech yeah me
start writing me when he first failed
wow wendy they hooked us up she wanted
me to advise him on how to do his case
and and uh
when uh when they told me when he told
me they offered him the 30 years you
know i told him that it was a good idea
to take it i'd say 30 years beat a life
sentence you know i knew guys and that's
because i had new guys who
had the opportunity to take 30 and
didn't
and got the life and had did 30 years
so so you can do 30 but you couldn't do
life right so sometimes you know you
might look at it like oh that's a lot of
time
but at the end of the day you got a date
you got a date and thirty might be
twenty five misha already misha how many
he's probably only like three years to
the house now that shit's crazy you know
he didn't did that [ __ ] so you just
think that he could have you know he
could have went hard and and got the
life sentence and and we'd be like oh he
ain't got no date did 50 cent ever try
to reach out to you to do 50 call me the
day i got out of jail because i feel
like he's been doing such a good job of
telling the bmf story with his show
you know but we wasn't able to put
nothing together you know uh
he might be able to do a much more
accurate version of what snowfall is but
like having you directly involved maybe
no i can do my own movie this is true i
know enough about i read enough books on
on producing movies that's true i read
about four or five books on producing
movies when i go talk to him you know i
met when i got out i met with rory
manuel i met with
jeff burr spencer boomer everybody uh
michael linton the the four biggest guys
in hollywood you know going to 50 cent
that's like a step down 100 percent so
so once i meet the top guys and they
didn't show me you know i didn't think
none of those guys were that smart
that's fair they couldn't even figure
out how i got in the offices
they're like wait who hey how did you
get here that's crazy i was like i was
invited
so when it comes to working with someone
like him and you you're helping it
advise them like what are the what are
some of the things that you're doing for
for for somebody like your guy right
here well well what what i'm showing him
is is that a lot of these guys
they're not their own men
you know they they don't make their own
decisions they they don't really think
for themselves uh they got other people
basically they're almost like puppets
you know when you look at most of these
guys
they they can
they can't do what they want to do
you know like with me i do whatever i
want to do i go when i want to go i go
to sleep when i want to go to sleep i
eat what i want to eat
nobody pays my bills i pay my own bills
so
that's the way
you got to be if you want to if you want
to have
i mean you got if you ain't got no
you got no nuts if you can't do that you
know you gotta tone down
to what other people tell you you have
to do you know and that's what i when i
met with those guys in hollywood that i
just named to you you know uh
or emmanuel tell me that i'm gonna have
to be listening to mark wahlberg no i
don't have to listen to mark wahlberg
you know i don't have to listen to
nobody because i already knew that i was
going to get out here and and and blaze
my own trail you know i get my mine out
the streets 20 at a time i just stacked
them 20s up you ain't got to give me you
know hundred thousand
well you know most people that's that's
the downfall to the music industry is
most artists are vulnerable and they get
that they'd rather take that upfront bag
even though the terms are terrible
then then take the slow monthly bag or
the slow residual income yeah i like
that though that's why i self-published
my book that's why i told him don't go
to amazon again
get it from your website
[Laughter]
i respect it i got i got a little artist
right now i'm trying to sign i got a 16
year old kid i ain't gonna mention his
name okay cause then you might you might
pop pop
some of my stealing from you yeah yeah
you know how they do so that's what's up
man and then we're gonna probably go to
the studio tonight you know what i'm
saying and uh was he hot too he had on
the mic
can he fight but he he can rap too are
you getting back into uh real estate at
all
i am but i'm gonna wait you know uh
uh i got my credit right
and you know now with my with my
marijuana grow you know i should be
making
a lot of millions million and a half a
month you know what i'm saying so
something like that i get into real
estate then something like that and and
that's real estate you know my building
i own the building there it is
definitely
you know what i'm saying did you ever
franchise any [ __ ] like any like did you
ever have like a subway or like a
mcdonald's back in the day ah no i
didn't know how to do that you know you
you and i i was a ghetto boy okay you
know my mom didn't
my mom the only job she ever had was
cleaning offices and cutting grass so
you know
you in order to do those type of things
you have to have somebody in your life
that has already done that uh you didn't
have that circle of people at the moment
my guys just carry guns right you know
they didn't carry books they carry guns
so
when when you have people who's coming
from those lifestyles
then
you can't expect anything else from them
and that's why i feel it's so important
for me to be successful because there's
so many young men you know like him who
need somebody like me to to show them
how far they can go like don't don't
limit yourself to just this you know the
world is yours you can do anything that
anybody else in this world can do and
and that's how i feel and and that's
what i try to teach my guys is that
don't let nobody muffle you down and
tell you how far you can grow and how
far you can go because they don't know
what you can do facts you know i don't
know what you can do you know so you
have to be the one that tells yourself
where your limits are and where you want
to stop uh last thing i wanted to ask
you about because i feel like what's
going on right now with fentanyl and all
the overdoses and people getting turnt
out over all these opiates
it's probably like the craziest like
surge of like a drug that's kind of like
taking over
in terms of like national media
attention probably since crack in the
80s right
when you see the what's going on with
fentanyl right now and like how a lot of
these pharmaceutical companies are kind
of skating because they're the source of
the problem and you know really
um
do you see the parallels and kind of
what was going on in the 80s to what's
going on now with fentanyl well fentanyl
kills his customers
you know with crack we didn't kill our
customers i didn't want to i didn't want
my customers to die i wanted them to
live because i know as long as they live
they was going to be bringing me that
money
and if you're killing your customers you
know almost like the cigarette companies
you got to recruit and i didn't want to
recruit i just wanted to keep the same
people keep coming keep on repeat
customers yeah we keep repeating we
always think of people who will sell
stuff to get crack what's the most
random thing someone brought to you in
exchange for crack a do a dope smoker
not somebody who
was was trying to sell but like what's
the craziest thing someone showed up to
to you with and said hey take this i
need this i need i need i need my fix
people don't offer everything man
putting their wives someone offered you
their wife yeah did you did you take it
no no
that was my homeboy your homie offered
you his wife because to get his fix he
thought i liked his wife so he's like yo
you can [ __ ] i just need some crack
exactly
what the [ __ ]
that's crazy what was what's the
craziest thing you accepted how about
that
i didn't i didn't really i didn't really
have to because
you weren't on that you weren't on that
line i didn't stay on the streets and
the transition
i was probably on the streets about two
or three months right you were by the
time you were really getting it going
you would you didn't even the hand
handshake was was was over
my hand in hand was real short you know
i i was able to
i got lucky because when i started my
mom when my mom put me out the house i
moved in with my cousin my cousin stayed
right around the corner from a pcp spot
so all the guys who sold pcp smoked
crack
that's crazy so every time they would
get a hundred dollars they would come
and see me so
mine went from making 20
to 500 a day like really quick as soon
as i found when i met the pcp guys all
the pcp guys
you know it was like 10 or 15 of them
out there so now i'm making a hundred
dollars from each one if they make 400 a
day they're going to give me hundred oh
that's crazy
someone offered you their wife that's
pretty wild yeah
i can imagine that there's yeah that's
wild well listen man um is there
anything going on like this very moment
you would like to promote yeah we got a
we got a big fight up in philadelphia on
the 25th of this month with my man
vashawn champ okay y'all be checking him
out another one of my guys
um
you're working a lot with fighters
well that's my my main passion right now
do we
the weed
well my passion is to take over boxing
did you get any pointers from jay prince
no because jay prince had his his bouts
with you know obviously managing floyd
mayweather and
jay you say you know jay doing his thing
yeah i mean we're gonna we gonna
probably be more like comp competitors
because we're gonna be we're gonna be
going for the same guys
you know pretty soon my guy's gonna be
beating his guys up
and anybody else's guys you know we uh
we want them belts we want to be the
best guys and not not for the money
because we're already going to be rich
you know we finna we're going to have
more money than seeing but we just want
to want to go in the ring and and beat
somebody up you know what i'm saying
boxing is so the 25th it's in philly the
fight yeah
so be on the lookout uh and it'll be
it'd be streamed on fight tv oh i got
fight tv oh you got flight tv yeah
you'll get to see it i um i think i saw
a fight what was one of the it was one
of the paul fights where he fought i
think tyron woodley was on there
that was on fight tv right
one of those were it was the one that
wasn't on trailer it was on fight tv
because that's what's on my channel
anybody anybody that wanted f-i-t-e if
they want to know exactly where to get
it then go to my page for ricky ross.com
freeway rick on instagram for ricky ross
on facebook and uh
tick tock is freeway rick and twitter
for a wreck what's your what's your
what's your social media so if anybody
want to follow you on my instagram pac
boy dot pbk man tap in with your baby
there it is across all platforms you
feel me we here
we taking over this year is gonna be a
good year for us there it is
appreciate you and your time man thank
you thank you that was good yes sir you
asked me some different stuff
all right we was off camera you were
talking about uh i asked you about doing
joe rogan you said you were the one of
the first joe rogan interviews how many
times have you done the joe rogan show
twice
you see we're like number 80 or
something yeah something like that i was
writing that number it might have been a
little earlier than that maybe even so i
go on joe rogan's show right and uh
i'm [ __ ] up at the time you know what
i'm saying that just took mom's house
you see my documentary when they put us
out on my opponent yeah yeah i i i've
seen it
they just put us out the house and um
i go do the joe rogan show but you know
i'm wearing it with you know like [ __ ]
it i i when i left prison i was already
like [ __ ] whatever i got to do if i'm
homeless even in the car i don't care
i'ma win you know like
i'm just a billionaire sleeping in the
car so when i go to joe rogan's show i
was like man joe i'm [ __ ] up
and he was like
man you need a t-shirt
and i almost put my head on the table
like oh
a t-shirt man give me some money
yeah i need a i need a i need a boost so
i need a show man i'm walking downtown
and uh
this young white kid come up to me and
he's like hey rick i heard you on the
joe rogan show he all geeked and [ __ ]
like that and i'm like oh man
he's like man i got an idea for a
t-shirt and i was like oh another one of
[ __ ] right
and uh he said the real rick ross is not
a rapper
and i say to myself that's the corniest
[ __ ] in the world but i always one thing
i notice about me is i keep an open mind
you know even though i might feel like a
certain way i ain't gonna like just say
like my way is the only way so
i said uh
all right let's do it the dude say i'll
print the t-shirt out design and
everything i don't know who this kid
either right
so he designed a t-shirt i come to a
shop we take some pictures with me
wearing his shirt and he give me a
hundred shirts i leave out and i sell
all those shirts that same day
wow
so at this time i got joe's direct
number i can call joe whenever i get
ready yeah so i called joe i was like
hey man you know you told me to do that
t-shirt well i did it i got a t-shirt
he's like all right
i'm gonna set you up to come back on the
show so the next week i go back on the
show and i take joe on the t-shirts
uh
because i i was doing them with really
nice material you know the new t-shirts
so i gave joe the shirt joe put the
shirt on on camera
and next week man my paypal hit like
eighteen thousand dollars like ping ping
ping that thing just kept going bing
bing bing bing bing bing we thought it
was broke
[Laughter]
eighteen thousand dollars was in my
paypal man we went got us apartment and
i ain't looked back since so that
that moment kind of helped
at that time was was you needed that
money i mean oh no we was [ __ ] up man
i had two babies i had two brand new
babies
danny my girl because i wanted to have a
son as soon as i got home because i knew
my time was running you know i'm an old
man now
right so as soon as you got home you got
to work well i i never i've never raised
a kid right
and and i've always wanted to you know
like i mean you know you could say i
raised my younger brothers but i slipped
on them because i would let them
you know go and do their own thing but
with my babies they don't get to do
nothing it's like of course you know
straight so joe rogan wearing that
t-shirt kind of
oh my goodness
i can't even say how many shirts that
thing sold because i rescued me on my
ass
[Music]
it did so well that t-shirt did so well
that right now it's like
five or six websites just bootlegging
that t-shirt that's so crazy i feel like
i've seen it like at the swap meet for
sure
the real red cross is not a rapper yeah
you know i still wear it
oh it's there
there it is right there i still wear
that joint go to the website and buy one
right now
when you when someone who's known joe
rogan as long as you have and you see
the controversy with uh you know what's
going on with him you know what are your
thoughts on that i don't think joe's a
racist
you know i mean a lot of people said i
mean i used to use the n-word
i used to use the n-word
but you know it's okay but it's a little
different when you use it yeah
but but uh it's it's i don't know but i
don't i don't feel like joe rogan is
racist you know i think he's getting a
bad uh rap for for for using the word
and he apologized and he's i don't
believe he'll ever use it again would
you go back on the show yeah i'll do joe
tomorrow i'll be i sell a million books
let's say you sell a lot more books a
lot more t-shirts now yeah if i go on
joe's show right now my book probably
wouldn't have been the best i mean my
book already you know i didn't really
need you i don't really need
nobody to do what i do for real uh my
book has done some numbers
you know just uh the way i sell it they
just don't uh calculate of course how
about so amazon let me say that there
and saying angle let amazon sell more of
my books than i sow i respect that